ford spends more money per car on health
insurance
than they do steel whoa employers
collectively spend
1.3 trillion dollars a year
funding health care for their employees
and
no one is satisfied there is not a
moment of health care the people like we
love it don't change it it's working the
value proposition is free
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
handling employee benefits is difficult
really really difficult
speaking from experience today i'm being
joined with amanda lennart
ceo of jellyvision maker of benefits
engagement platform alex
more than 1500 companies including 114
of the fortune 500 and two-fifths of the
country's 25 largest companies
use alex to help their employees
understand complex topics
from choosing a health care insurance
plan to saving for retirement or
navigating a leave of absence
welcome amanda amanda leonard welcome to
20 minute leaders
ceo of jelly vision all the way from
chicago how are you doing
i'm doing great and i'm delighted to be
here thanks for having me
if i were to begin to articulate your or
describe your journey with all the
massive awards you've gotten whether
it's ceo of the year woman of the year
from from the different organizations
we're not going to end this podcast ever
but
today we're going to be focusing on your
journey as well as your leadership and
jelly vision
employee decision making and i'm really
excited to dive deep into this world of
employee decision making because i have
no idea
what it's like except for my own
personal experiences that i know that
it's
freaking difficult to make decisions as
an employee
it's complicated it's cumbersome but
before we get to that amanda tell me a
little bit about
who you are how how do you sort of live
your life or how do you see your career
trajectory
yeah i i'm the kid of academics my my
dad was a doctor knew exactly what he
wanted to be from the time he was 15
years old studied for 15 years to get
there and did nothing but that one job
my mom was a nurse turned stay-at-home
mom and so i grew up in a household
where it was important to study
and to learn how to learn but it wasn't
entrepreneurial and it didn't have
anything to do with business so i
studied august into romantic literature
in school with a um concentration in
biology
yeah yeah i i was an english nerd um and
my plan was to get a jd
md and write public policy for hospitals
about
what you know sort of like when you're
at the the intersection of ethics and
science what do you do
um but when i spent my junior year
abroad at the university of edinburgh in
scotland
and studied mostly beer and boys and got
behind in my pre-med credits
and my dad told me he wasn't gonna pay
for a fifth year of undergrad
i knew i was off the dole i had no
skills no experience and no network
whatsoever
and had to go get a job um so i ended up
in
advertising and and and my sort of first
job out of
college graduated on a friday showed up
uh at a job on monday
and i've been incredibly lucky ever
since with sort of this like
being at the right place right time and
always working hard and i've
sort of become an accidental
entrepreneur deeply involved in tech
uh no one you know let alone me ever saw
it coming that i'd be a ceo of a tech
company but i'm certainly
certainly enjoying the ride and you're
like who am i
uh a person with a lot of curiosity
a lot of energy um always evolving
always learning uh and excited about
just about anything if i look at it long
enough i will find a reason to find it
deeply fascinating
um and i also have a great sense of
humor uh like to laugh like to make sure
that everything is fun if it can be
uh and that's how i've gone through life
i love it you know one of the things
that i'm getting so much inspiration to
this show
you know it seems that you know the
unifying factor for for leaders is the
fact that they they can become
passionate if they think
long enough about a problem and and it's
not that they're necessarily attached to
one specific thing but they
but they get excited about problem
solving and about the infinite
complexity that a problem can have and
all the different layers
and so over the past nine years you're
focusing on
jelly vision tell me a little bit about
what that is and and
and your entrance to this role
yeah the entrance to the role has been a
long and windy road um
jelly vision in its first version was a
film company
and then an educational software company
and then a gaming company they got
really famous in the
90s making games like you don't know
jack and who wants to be a millionaire
where we created virtual game show hosts
wow on these things called cd-roms that
would go into your computer and hold
data
i thought it would be the internet uh
came to be
exactly you use them as a coaster uh
when when the internet happened and
cd-roms died so too did our aspirations
to be in gaming and we switched from
creating virtual game show hosts in a
b2c gaming space
to creating virtual advisors in a b2b
enterprise space
the company's thesis was we're going to
go to where there's furrowed brow
where people are trying to do something
complicated and boring
but important and we'll talk them
through it
and it turns out after seven years or so
eight years of operating as a digital
agency
and always wanting to productize and
scale what we do
we landed in healthcare and to try to
set the stage about healthcare in
america
ford spends more money per car on health
insurance than they do steel
employers collectively spend 1.3
trillion dollars a year
funding health care for their employees
and
no one is satisfied there is not a
moment of health care the people like we
love it don't change it it's working the
value proposition is free
so what we do is we materially reduce
the cost
of benefits confusion for the employers
and employees and let's be clear
healthcare is too expensive and billions
and billions hundreds of billions of
dollars in fact are wasted every year
sometimes they're it's wasted because of
systemic
inefficiencies too many people in the
ecosystem
and other times it's wasted because
sometimes humans make bad decisions
we really sit at the forefront of
decisions that where human capacity
around decision making could be better
could be improved
and we sell things like math but we use
our gaming days and our ability to
engage and entertain to get people to be
less stressed
we make thinking about mortality
and sickness and needs of protection we
can make it palatable
and make people feel really confident
around the decisions that come
come down to having access to and
financing
healthcare health insurance voluntary
benefits the things
that are really important to your family
amanda take me take me
two steps back for a second because
we're we're talking about the complexity
and the confusion i experienced this
firsthand
to to a lot of people here that may not
have experienced this yet why
is it such a confusing uh you know
problem to tackle and it's one that i
guess every person
needs to tackle at some point why is it
so confusing
well it's confusing because of the way
we have we have a middle payer model
right we have
companies that provide care we have
companies that insure
or provide payment for care and then we
have companies who sponsor
care your employer and then the fourth
leg is we have people who use care
and this ecosystem does not agree they
don't have a line incentives about how
to make money what quality means
and what appropriate behaviors are
carriers fundamentally make money by
more care and more expensive care
employers are incented to have
the right care the quality care and
employees sometimes confuse
quality care with good bedside manner my
doctor sees me quickly when i want to
see him
never mind the fact that the fact that
you've had seven visits over one
condition is a problem
it should have been one and done so very
very different constituents with
different versions of success different
needs and so on
but like just to kind of like lay out
what's going on in the country
now seven years ago or so to be
provocative you'd say
every company is a tech company because
of
automation and machine learning and
computing power and you know it's kind
of like yeah every company is a tech
company
now you can easily say every company is
a health care company
and i'm not talking because of covet of
vaccinations and sanitation stations and
protocols
the world of benefits and sort of health
insurance has changed
so much over the last 10 years all
because employers are trying to better
manage the cost of health care
right so it used to be here's some
medical insurance here's some dental
insurance
here's some voluntary benefits and
here's your paid leave
and now employers are in the business of
offering
chronic care condition solutions care
navigation solutions
pharmaceutical savings products and
services
all designed to help employees get the
care they need
more effectively and for a lower cost
because it's just on this unsustainable
trajectory for everyone
um consumerism has largely been a hey we
can't pay any more as an employer so you
need to pay
employee but we really haven't cracked
the nut on driving better health
health like decisions and that's what
jelly vision is really focusing on is
enabling better decisions
that save everybody in the ecosystem
money while getting people the care that
they need
so what have you learned about this
decision making that you know the jelly
the jelly vision is really tackling what
what part of the decision making process
are you i heard before that you're you
know the gamification part of it or the
you know the way that you're approaching
some some topics that otherwise may not
be very approachable
how does television actually go into
this incredibly sounds like complicated
process
and and makes it different so the first
thing is
the first thing is despite being in the
world of benefits education
we know the vast majority of people do
not want a phd
in healthcare they want to make a good
decision
and then not think about it again until
they
absolutely need to so just to be clear
it's a very high threshold for like
information to really be able to make
good decisions and a very low appetite
for investing and getting you know
mastery of that information yeah
so we use that to try to create the
optics of ease we really really try to
reduce
you know fatigue and too much
information make it as simple as
possible and importantly we make it as
contextualized as possible
you don't have to learn about everything
about benefits you just need to learn
about what matters
to you and then we use plain english
stress reducing mechanics you know
persuasion architecture
all around trying to sell math because
our algorithm is
truly about what is in the lowest annual
out analyze out-of-pocket
investments for employees we really do
have their interests in mind
and that leads to trust and trust leads
to better decision making more
engagement etc
now as the leader of this company you
and when you're going about
trying to make it you know a smoother
process you know
there's one aspect of it which i'm
hearing is more of the algorithmic side
and more of
you know understanding what is what is
you know the recommended approach but
then there's also the messaging behind
it that it sounds to me like that's a
pretty crucial
aspect correct me if i'm wrong how do
you actually go about
you know figuring out what is the right
messaging what is the right approach how
do you make people
you know feel better with what they're
doing how do you even because it's not
an exact science you're exactly right
there are a lot of components to our
solution that range from really complex
algorithms you know machine learning
processing
millions of claims you know on a
national basis but the reality is
we have developed a software
presentation layer
that is as humanistic as possible
whether it is literally a voice from
behind the screen talking to you
even in our writing we write the way
people talk
we make incredibly simple word choices
we
use metaphor and analogies to paint
pictures in people's heads so
it is sort of communication on top and
incredibly
you know complex boolean logic based
decision trees for managing all the
variables
it's it's you know massive amounts of
claims data it's very complex parsing
systems so we can optimize
for 2 000 different benefit eligibility
classes and tons of different plans
under the hood
but it really is like typically imagine
you're like i don't know what to do what
do i do i pick somebody a call somebody
tell me what to do yeah
we try to simulate that call of like
what would that person ask you and how
can we make it as simple and humanistic
and
as much about you instead of about
benefits as possible
so you quickly get to what's the right
answer you quickly make good
mathematical decisions and then you get
on with your life
which is really what everybody wants to
do as quickly as possible well
and nobody wakes up and says today is a
tuesday
i'm gonna go shopping for benefits like
you have to do it it's important to do
it
but uh no one is excited about our
vertical ever
i think that i procrastinated for for
quite some time with my decisions
and i and i'm sure that i'm not the only
one it's it's it's scary
it's a scary decision you you feel that
you're underprepared no matter what
and so you avoid the decision and it
makes perfect sense and i and i
understand
you know how big of a problem it is at
least from my perspective and so i think
it's fantastic what you're doing
give me a few a little bit of you know
context jelly vision today
what what's actually happening how many
companies is it is it helping operate
a little bit about the ecosystem
yeah we have more than 300 employees
more than 1600
uh employer customers who employ
18 million employees and uh last year we
did about 110 billion dollars worth of
insurance premiums through our platform
so definitely size and scale the market
leader in the space we are
um and i say this humbly because we
worked a really long time and really
you know listen to our customers to get
there but we're definitely the market
leader in the space by far
and over the past nine years you're
watching it grow what is it like now
looking back nine years and is this what
you expected were there any
you know huge surprises along the way
was it just a clear-cut journey of
knowing what to do
i you know what the the road up is never
this right that's
that to me is a myth it's this right so
it feels like you're always just hanging
on by your fingertips like if we're
getting really real about it like it's
just not a linear progression
but i like i remember moments it's all
kinds of moments first of all there is
no
ultimate milestone whether it's a
fundraise or
hitting 10 million in arr or 50 million
in arr like
there is no milestone there are only
more peaks so you got to pace yourself
that's sort of my advice it's like
there's no finish line in business
and i remember when i finally realized
we were
the market leader i finally realized we
were we were people
knew about us before we introduced
ourselves like there's that weird moment
where you're like you're heard of and
you're not used to it you're used to
saying
hi i'm amanda from jellyvision we make
alex and alex's
this thing and if i feel like yeah we
know jelly vision once that happens and
like you're known ahead of introducing
yourself
you have a split second of being like oh
my gosh
all this work were there before you
realize they're now 50 competitors
directly targeting you in your book of
business and i remember saying like can
you give me a week
couldn't you give me a week to just be
like wow but no
then you start going art you have to
play offense and a little bit of defense
but only five percent defense
90 95 offense or you'll lose your edge
right
and it's it's there's really very little
moment for
deep reflection and enjoyment of the
winds like we get really critical
and analytical about our losses and then
the winds sort of happen and
you set the bar instantly rises and
you're on to the next one there's not a
lot of like
gloating i i don't think in business to
be fair i mean we might have a beer
and and and spend time appreciating
co-workers but there's no like
awesome sauce you just it's more and
next and and
and better right small celebrations and
then quickly go on to the next problem
because they're they're infinite
uh now it i can see the excitement
coming from here
if you look over your you know your
journey or at least specifically in
jelly vision
what what do you enjoy most if you had
to to drill it down to to one aspect of
of the jelly vision journey
whether it's the leadership it's the
customer happiness it's the
you know the b2b to see whatever it may
be
what do you what do you what does it
come down to for you
yeah what makes me tick so i think there
are different kinds of ceos you know
they're
they're financial ceos who are masters
at fundraising and they're always
raising capitalizing the business
there are um ceos who are are
product visionaries right they're all
kinds of different c ceos
uh to me i'm i'm a people ceo
my job description is take care of the
people so they take care of everything
else and make sure we don't run out of
money so you know financing the business
but
uh what what i am drawn to what blows me
away is
are my co-workers they're not just like
talented and hardworking
and humble but they're usually hilarious
and like deeply
interesting maybe slightly weird but in
a really fantastic way
uh people so getting to know my
co-workers and seeing sort of their
brilliance
is absolutely the glue for me it's
probably the glue for most people at
jellyvision
and the second thing is i like working
on a problem that matters
like taking a dent out of this problem
it matters if we do our job well we can
we can save a family material money
you know like i i like that part of
winning winning by doing that feels good
to me
right and it's not just about the you
know the until now we've spoken
primarily about the experience of making
the decision but it's actually much more
than that it's actually this idea that
you know by making the experience better
you're actually enabling better decision
making and
you know if you need to use the
insurance or the benefits that's when it
really counts and if you got if you
didn't get the right one
you then then that really hurts but if
you got the right one then it makes your
life a whole lot easier amanda thank you
so much for coming uh
20 minutes is way too short i have so
many more questions for you but
i have three short ones that i have to
ask and the first one
is what is your favorite subject from
middle school or high school
for sure despite being an english major
it's history okay um i know history
specifically about countries and
governments but to me it's about you
know
people and stories uh and i really like
studying the past to get lessons for the
future so i'm going to say history
wonderful and one of your role models
somebody that inspires you
i have way too many mentors to be able
to answer this question easily there are
so many people who are so generous and
will
you know tell me the truth but still
have my back
so i'm going to go for someone i have
never met which is ruth
bader ginsburg and the reason i'm going
with rbg
is she's incredibly self-made she's
absolutely a fighter
she is a warrior powerful but it's never
about ego
it's about others and i really really
respect how hard she worked to get
powerful and then she used all of her
power for other people
to me that's like the ultimate queen
move it's just
such an impressive legacy she left
behind i love it and what are three
words that you would choose to describe
yourself
the hardest question so i knew this
question was coming
and it is the worst question where i was
like man i could answer anything about
business or
whatever so i actually asked a few of my
colleagues what three words best
describe me because i want to punt this
one
and they all three said passionate which
is i know one of
the sort of purpose things is like
discovering the passion and curiosity
their everything so i didn't want to use
passion so i'm gonna go
with um learning okay
direct yes and insightful yes but
probably the three words
really best describing our mom wife and
advisor
i love it and the passion you know
throughout the last 20 minutes it just
exudes the screen
completely and i and i love it amanda
thank you very very much
stay safe stay healthy thank you for
taking the time to join me and
thank you for for making a lot of
people's lives much better
it's it's really it's really a an honor
to talk to you here
thank you for this opportunity for this
format and for the stories you're
telling i've i've really enjoyed getting
to know your content i think it's
incredibly cool
thank you so much thank you amanda
bye-bye